más ayuda económica para Ucrania
46 países y 24 organizaciones
internacionales se reunieron en Francia
en el marco de la conferencia en favor
de Ucrania en la cual los asistentes se
comprometieron a realizar pagos y ayudas
por más de mil millones de euros los
cuales estarán distribuidos así
semilla
dentro de estos mil millones aquí hay
algunas cifras principales 415 millones
para energía 25 millones para agua 38
millones para recursos alimentarios
17 millones para salud 22 millones para
transporte y cuatrocientos noventa y
seis millones más que aún no están
designados el total supera ligeramente
los mil millones
además Suecia anunció 58 millones de
dólares adicionales en ayuda humanitaria
para la reconstrucción de escuelas
hospitales e infraestructuras mientras
que Francia suministrará 63 nuevos
generadores eléctricos de alta potencia
y varios transformadores que se sumarán
a los 100 ya entregados en noviembre en
representación de Ucrania asistieron la
primera dama y el Primer Ministro quien
aseguró que Rusia pretende crear una
nueva oleada de refugiados hacia Europa
por su parte el presidente boludo
de manera virtual y presentó una lista
de necesidades inmediatas que incluyen
vehículos blindados y chalecos antibalas
para sus tropas todos los días nuestros
trabajadores de la energía tienen que
desconectar a millones de ucranianos del
suministro debido a una escasez crítica
de Electricidad ahora mismo unas 12
millones de personas en casi todas las
regiones y la capital están
desconectadas del suministro entre tanto
Rusia continúa atacando diariamente
desde octubre la infraestructura vital
de Ucrania como estrategia para
debilitar a sus habitantes Durante este
invierno que según kiev afecta acerca de
la mitad de la infraestructura
energética de Ucrania